he is 95 years old a few days before the
70th anniversary commemorations Joseph
Kosinski spoke with journalists about
his years in captivity he was number 120
one of more than 700 young poles that
made up the first shipment of slave
laborers to Auschwitz camp commander Col
fridge welcomed them personally I've
never forgotten his words I was standing
in the front row and this is what he
told us you have no idea where you've
ended up this is no sanatorium it's a
German concentration camp your life
expectancy here is three months at the
most priests and Jews will be dead
within six weeks if one can speak of
good fortune at auschwitz patch in ski
seemed to have it he was put to work as
a barber for SS officers one day he was
invited to the senior commanders Villa
to cut his hair I was afraid trembling I
couldn't see straight
his wife escorted me to his bathroom on
the first floor then who doll first
entered he never said a word how you
simply took a seat and I began I'd seen
him before in the barbershop and
observed how my predecessor cut his hair
they did the same patch in ski became
hearses personal barber and so survived
five years of Auschwitz he was among the
first prisoners there and saw the last
train arrive in January 1945 one week
before the camp was liberated he and
hundreds of others were shipped to
another camp patch in ski shunned
Auschwitz for decades after the war his
return this time was still difficult
it stayed with me all these years I
still feel it when I go there I can see
everything so vividly
my friends mothers with children in
their arms all going to their deaths how
could it happen 70 years later Joseph
Kosinski is still seeking the answer to
that question he isn't attending the
70th anniversary commemorations he fears
the memories would be unbearable